good afternoon on behalf of the Terry
lectures committee I would like to thank
you for joining us for the second
installment of the 2015 Terry lectures I
am Jean Thompson black senior executive
editor at Yale University Press the
Dwight H Terry lectureship which was
established in 1905 by a gift from
Dwight Harrington Terry Bridgeport
Connecticut invites pre eminent scholars
and religion the sciences and philosophy
to address issues concerning the ways in
which science and philosophy inform
religion and religions application to
human welfare we are delighted that
janet brown arrow mount professor of the
history of science at Harvard University
is our 2015 lecturer at Harvard
professor Brown teaches the history of
biology including the history of
evolutionary theory her interests range
widely over the life sciences botany the
history of gardens collecting
expeditions museums and Natural History
she has been at Harvard since 2006 and
is currently chair of the history of
science department previously she taught
at the wellcome trust center for the
history of medicine at University
College London and was an associate
editor of the early volumes of the
correspondence of Charles Darwin in
Cambridge England she has been editor of
the british journal for the history of
science and president of the british
society for the history of science in
2002 she completed a two-volume
biography of Charles Darwin that
integrated Darwin's science with his
life and times she is vice president of
the history of science society and Chair
Elect of the history of the section on
history and philosophy of science for
the American Association for the
Advancement of science today professor
Brown will present her section second
lecture in the three-part series
becoming Darwin history memory and
biography in the first lecture which we
enjoyed on Tuesday November 3 she
considered the subject of Charles Darwin
as in the
economist of nature her presentation
painted a portrait of Darwin as an
accountant and one for whom the minus
details of household accounts and
personal finance greatly influenced all
other aspects of his thinking values and
scientific pursuits this perspective
also situated his theory of evolution by
natural selection with 19th century
economic theory and moral values today
her lecture will focus on the long
tradition of biographies of Darwin one
of the most pleasurable aspects of the
Terry lectures is the opportunity to
converse with the lecturer informally
earlier this week over a lunch
conversation professor Browne revealed
that at one time in her life and before
she undertook her graduate training in
history of science she was engaged in
the business of selling antiquarian
books in the course of sorting through a
collection of books and other print
materials the business had acquired she
discovered a pamphlet with handwritten
notes which upon further investigation
were indeed annotations by Charles
Darwin that pamphlet today resides in
the archives of the American
Philosophical Society in Philadelphia at
the conclusion of today's lecture there
will be an opportunity to ask questions
the lectures are being videoed for
subsequent web transmission so if you
would like to ask a question please use
one of the microphones available we then
invite you to attend a reception to be
held at the other end of the quarter
here at the Whitney Humanities Center in
closing could I please remind you to
turn off or silence cellphones and now
please join me in welcoming back janet
brown
thank you very much Jean and thank you
all for either returning or making your
first visit to this series of lectures
welcome to you all so nice to see you
and i'm going to start straight in
without too much preamble several of my
colleagues who I can see here in the
audience today have probably seen this
image before but I think it's so unusual
that it's worth another outing it's
photograph as you can see it was
published in the 1970s and it purports
to show a photographic image of Charles
Darwin's ghost taking a midnight stroll
and according to the photographer who
seems to be perfectly genuine he can be
seen in hat and cloak with his walking
stick and his telltale beard so please
if you see him I really would want to
know your guess is absolutely as good as
mine I have shown it before and people
have made suggestions and they's have
suggested perhaps he's perhaps he's here
and that leaves out all this side of the
image it's very perplexing it may be a
hoax and probably as a hote but it does
pose a very intriguing visual puzzle and
it also calls into our belief systems
generally speaking is that some of us
will be willing to find him there and
some of us won't so I'm dealing with the
after lives of a prominent scientist in
this talk today and the after lives of
someone as prominent as Darwin usually
much more obvious than the possibilities
we see here I'm going to be following
very appreciative Lee in the footsteps
of a number of scholars who have worked
on commemorative activities biographical
traditions and celebratory occasions in
the sciences and and in other places and
I'm going to be calling attention to the
manner in which Darwin has been
constructed and reconstructed through a
number of different biographies written
in English there were obviously
different Darwin's for different
circumstances each one molded to fit the
occasion and in the previous lecture on
Tuesday I tried to show something of
Darwin's character and the way that he
depended on creating order and stability
out of a huge variety of data I
mentioned his ability and financial
investment
his account book mentality his
compulsion to list things and his sense
that economic probity was also a moral
virtue and tonight I want to focus on
something of the same theme of virtue on
the written accounts of Darwin's life
and next week I want to be looking more
at the visual records of Darwin's life
Bernie Lightman and I have shown in
recent essays that they've been around
30 or so biographies of Darwin that are
strictly speaking biographies there's
many hundreds perhaps even more than a
thousand studies of Darwin's works and
often they use his life in order to
engage with his works but a classic
biography that we all understand what
shape that might take there's actually
only been about 30 since his death in
1880 230 is somewhat more than Isaac
Newton but considerably less than Mary
Curie so we have individual here who has
a substantial biographical tradition but
it's not overwhelmingly huge one leading
feature that bears special consideration
that I'm going to turn to today is the
way that Darwin's moral life was
presented by successive authors now
actually Darwin was his own first
biographer whilst he was in his sixties
he wrote a document called by him
recollections of the development of my
mind and character and here's the table
of contents from the first manuscript
version of this and it's actually so I
shouldn't have said the first manuscript
version there's a very scrappy heavily
altered and annotated version that was
the first version that was written over
several years beginning in 1876 this is
the clean copy that Darwin unusually
wrote out for himself instead of paying
the village school
to do it for him that's Darwin's
handwriting you won't be able to read
too much of it from the distance that
you are at but you see it says table of
contents from my birth to going is the
first one Cambridge life voyage of the
Beagle etc etc so he began it in May
1876 at the same time as he was writing
a biographical memoir of his grandfather
dr. Erasmus Darwin the poet evolutionary
thinker and medical man and that memoir
of Erasmus Darwin which Darwin very much
enjoyed researching and writing plus the
exciting news of the first grandchild on
the way encouraged him to begin an essay
of his own he took no care over style he
didn't bother to pursue episodes that
escaped his memory he didn't check dates
and he let his narrative move forward in
a very straightforward line towards his
different achievements principally the
origin of species and because it was not
meant to be read by anyone other than
their family and as a result the work
embodied many of the charms and
eccentricities and oddities of an
English gentleman at home it was very
polite was very considerate it was
amusingly self-deprecating and yet
Darwin seems to have been unable or
unwilling to delve too far beneath the
surface a much more demanding editor or
author might have asked himself much
more penetrating questions but in
choosing which memories to record and in
selecting the anecdotes that he gave
varied freely he was constructing
himself in the way that he wanted to be
in the way that he wanted to know
himself and in the way that he wanted to
be remembered Roy Pascal the literary
scholar noted more than 30 years ago
that scientists often feel that
personal experiences are somehow
irrelevant to the story of their
scientific achievement and we may have
scientists in the audience who might
want to feedback on that question in
question time personal experiences
perhaps are irrelevant to the story of
their achievement since it's the
achievement who defines who they are it
doesn't mean that scientists have a
lesser emotional life but that they
retrospectively see their lives playing
out towards the scientific achievement
and they don't see that there's much
purpose in putting in all the other
details of their private lives so Darwin
evidently had this point of view this
sense of himself he saw the idea of
evolution by natural selection as the
main purpose retrospectively of his life
and for the most part he described
himself as a series of books and towards
the end his memoir Darwin did try to
estimate his character reflecting on the
issues of that many Inquirer's had asked
him but also particularly on the
questions set before him in the
questionnaire that I showed on tuesday
sent to him by Francis Galton asking
about his character but he wasn't
introspective by nature nor did he find
it appropriate to mention the financial
affairs that I discussed in great detail
on Tuesday the big silences in Victorian
autobiography were sex and money nobody
talked about sex or money in their
autobiographies even though they formed
the topics of almost every novel of the
period it was just not polite to do that
what's less noticed perhaps some of you
will be familiar with this autobiography
what's less noticed is the way that
Darwin emphasized his own
personal effort presenting himself as a
man committed to the ethos of self-help
a part of his identity that evidently
drew on the contemporary ideals of
character self-determination enterprise
that were encountered in Samuel smiles
his books of the period darn seems to
have believed that everything he
achieved had been the result of his own
industry looking back he reckoned he had
learned nothing at school nothing from
his father who's here on the left in
this image nothing from his father who
was a very intelligent medical man
Robert where in Darwin on the left there
considered Darwin a very ordinary boy
and it's that phrase that Darwin
remembers in his 60s early 70s to record
about his father he claims he gained
nothing from lectures at two great
universities Cambridge and Edinburgh he
claimed that in Edinburgh as a student
he had listened to Robert grants
eloquent advocacy of the evolutionary
ideas of Lamarck jean-baptiste Lamarck
and Darwin says in his autobiography
without any effect on my mind similarly
he stated that the evolutionary views of
his grandfather dr. Erasmus Darwin who's
here on the right the net for one
generation further back Erasmus Darwin
had been a very prominent evolutionary
thinker and writer and Darwin similarly
says that his grandfather's evolutionary
views produced no effect on me so
there's a decidedly self-congratulatory
heir to this Darwin couldn't even
believe that the subject of evolution
had been in the air when he published we
know absolutely that that's a false
memory so all these opinions conveyed a
commitment to personal autonomy this was
the
age of individuality of laissez-faire
Darwin was writing a kind of capitalist
autobiography where his everyday traits
were turned by skill and personal effort
into assets it was full about masculine
it was full of masculine assumptions
about the world of work and personal
effort positive intellectual activity
Darwin's moments of uncertainty the
enormous efforts made by his friends and
his family to support him the generosity
of other colleagues which historians
know about from the very large archival
record all went unmentioned by him we
also look in vain for a moment of
Epiphany as might be find in other
autobiographical reflections such as
Russo's confessions or John Henry
Newman's apologia pro vita sua apology
for my life there is a course Darwin's
self description of his delightful self
description of his carefree innocence
and his zest for collecting Natural
History specimens before and during the
Beagle voyage he always believed as
indeed we still do today that the Beagle
voyage was the turning point in his life
it was the voyage that made him what he
became subsequently and also in this
autobiography he did attempt to explain
his religious beliefs he was by then the
celebrated author of On the Origin of
Species he was the presumed skeptic who
had overturned Victorian ideas about
Adam and Eve he felt obliged to describe
what he at that point thought he had
become in religious terms so his
personal loss of faith was described by
him as a gradual transition from an
early relatively low-key Unitarian
family training to a state of mind where
he constantly questioned the role of an
interventionist
in nature he wrote with some humor about
the original plan to become a clergyman
but he recorded that he when he was
faced by a family tragedy which was the
death of this his oldest daughter Anne
in 1851 at the age of 10 her unexpected
death from illness surely we all now
think wiped out the last shreds of his
belief in conventional Christianity yet
I do think it's fair to say that Darwin
never really rejected the idea of an
ultimate divinity and he was very glad
when thomas henry huxley his friend as
our colleague the late frank turner was
one of the first to notice when Huxley
coined the word agnostic this helped a
large number of scientists in the 1870s
1880s to put a word on to what they
fought about these big issues it's a
word that simply expresses they didn't
know they didn't know what to believe
there was no evidence that fell into the
normal domain of scientific evidence so
agnostic as a word was something that
Darwin tended to use a lot about himself
after eighteen seventy when Huxley
brought it to his attention and on the
theme of Darwin's religious beliefs you
may well have seen this astonishing
letter which came up for sale in
September this year and in bonhams New
York in which Darwin very astringent Lee
States his point of view and so here
you'll see I'm sorry to have to inform
you that i do not believe in the bible
as a divine revelation and therefore not
in Jesus Christ as the Son of God it's
pretty terse isn't it
and I think if we put this in historical
context it is actually amazing to see
Darwin say this kind of thing and indeed
on a letter that is up for sale for
collectors it fetched the highest price
ever for a Darwin letter a hundred and
ninety seven thousand dollars it was
written it has been known about for some
time but it's not been on the market for
forever it was written in 1880 in
response to a young Christian lawyer
called Francis McDermott who told Darwin
who could not and would not read the
origin of species unless he knew that
the author was a believer both in the
Bible as the revealed Word of God and in
Jesus Christ so this possibly explains
the wording of the letter and a little
bit of the exasperation because nobody
likes to be sent a letter saying well
I'm not going to read you unless you can
tell me something more about your
religious faith but please notice he
doesn't deny the existence of a divinity
and in his autobiography he said that he
rejected all the sort of apparatus of
Christianity the churches the baptism
the thirty-nine articles in those days
that you were meant to sign and in his
autobiography he said that he probably
deserved to be called assessed he was
very concerned about deity about
freewill about the apparent existence of
design in nature and he explored these
topics these very deep and difficult
topics in correspondence with the
American botanist ASA gray and also
touchingly in a few letters exchanged
between him and his wife Emma and Darwin
mentions those letters from his wife
also in his autobiography as to how he
read them wasn't quite able to conform
with her wishes and there's one I
unfortunately don't have an image of it
there's one letter from his wife that he
has obviously kept because it's in the
archive still it's all folded up it's
all
kind of dirty around the falls and a
long one margin he's written know that
when I when know that when I've died
that I have kissed and cried over this
so it's very sweet it's very touching
it's very personal it's moments like
that that historians feel privileged to
be in an archive when you gettin real
insight into someone's private life he
couldn't go as far as his wife Emma in
belief but I think he didn't ever quite
give up a sense of something divine in
nature so he was always sensitive to his
wife's belief in established doctrine
although she too was brought up rather
lacks Lee as a Unitarian and she
mentions in her own manuscripts that her
own faith declined as she grew older
here she is in old age she was I think
not a member of the theological police
that is she's often painted ass in some
of the biographies that I might be
mentioning today so this is the story as
Darwin more or less told it and my
question now is how did the biographers
tell it the foundation document in the
biographical tradition is the life and
letters of Charles Darwin a three-volume
book published in eighteen eighty seven
five years after he died prepared by
Darwin's third son Francis Frank it was
published fairly rapidly only five years
as I said in order to insure that the
family kept a really close agency in
regulating how his intellectual legacy
was to be understood immediately after
Darwin's death the five sons began
soliciting papers and correspondence
from his friends they were then cat
ported into action they haven't been
planning to move so fast but they were
catapulted into action by a pamphlet
published the year after
by Edward Aveling the socialist
philosopher stating that Darwin was an
atheist and the boys wrote to each other
in some agitation who knew what might be
next and those who opposed religion in
those days often took Darwin as their
inspiration and they expected his
support for their cause which was a role
that he had very firmly rejected in his
lifetime so the issue became more
problematic for the Darwin family almost
immediately afterwards when the
journalist an anthropologist grant Allen
the Canadian anthropologist published a
quick and easy biography drawing on his
acquaintance with Thomas Henry Huxley
and the abundant Darwinian literature
that was already circulating so Francis
Frank who had served as Darwin's
scientific secretary and botanical
co-author for more than a decade felt
that he should hurry through an
authorized biography that the family
should produce it and his own
correspondence is rather interesting
about this about the wish to honor his
father and preserve his memory even to
the point of some self identification
and I just returned to this image of
Francis because he looks a bit like
Darwin but all those sons looked a bit
like Darwin and I'll show you that in
just a moment but he's wearing Darwin's
cape that they had given him as a
birthday present when he was 70 not so
many years previously so it's quite I
think it's a little bit worrying myself
but it's quite interesting that he
chooses to be painted by his friend
William R often Stein asked Darwin but
anyway he's Frances more than any other
of the family made his reputation on
being Charles Darwin son and the
Heritage industry today would probably
call that being a
she'll all descendant but he did write a
very nice life and letters which I'll
come to in just a moment as an aside
it's such pity that the by nikki is
closed at the moment but there's a very
remarkable letter in the bar Nicki
library here written by Darwin's
daughter Henrietta to a woman called
Camilla Ludwig who was a governess to
the Darwin children to Henrietta when
she was a go to inform Camilla of
Darwin's death and Camilla had been a
great favorite of Charles Darwin's
because she translated great washes of
Germans scientific work for him and
those translations have been in the
Darwin archive handwritten translations
for many many years nobody knowing who
had been the translator but it's from
this letter in the by Nikki that we know
now that it was Camilla the governess
who did it for him and he was very he
liked kimmel elude look very much so
Frances darlin here brought great
personal knowledge literary ability and
strong scientific sympathy to the life
and letters of Charles Darwin and his
volumes although it's a completely
conventional genre were in fact
innovative in revealing quite a lot
about the private man the bulk of the
book was letters as the title suggests
and these offered behind-the-scenes
insight into Darwin's work and
introductory chapters included
reminiscences contributed by the family
and friends and there was an account by
Francis of his father's working life and
these and the narrative arc in general
contribute to the making of a scientific
hero Huxley who was still alive supplied
a very vigorous chapter about the
reception of the origin of species and
there were lists of publications there
were portraits there was honorary
degrees and in appendix giving the
citation for Darwin's burial in West
Minster Abby so it's a very complete
account of the man's life and Francis
included Darwin's autobiographical
memoir that I've been talking about much
has been made of the way that this was
edited down the religious material was
taken out and that son's the five sons
discussed the matter of publication in
edited form quite extensively and here
are three of the sons without Francis
who we've already seen this is in age
order George was older than Francis and
then there's Leonard Joe Francis comes
in between George and Leonard and then
there's Horus the youngest son there are
hardly any photographs of the oldest son
William Darwin who is here pictured in
considerably old age with his sister
Henrietta there's one member of the
family who is very rarely photographed
as well Elizabeth Darwin the daughter
who doesn't feature in the historical
record very much certainly not in the
photographic record so if Emma Darwin's
request Darwin's wife requested that the
boys should remove several sentences
from Darwin's autobiography that talk
about his religious loss of his loss of
religious faith Emma felt that the
sentences expressed very contemptuous
opinions on points of Christian doctrine
the boys were reluctant to do so they
took advice from Leslie Stephen who was
both a member of the same Bloomsbury set
that they belong to but also editor of
the British dictionary of national
biography and they took advice from
Huxley both of whom said publish but
Emma Darwin was very firm Marvel was
very firm and she specified that she
didn't wish to upset family members or
friends who might be offended at least
that's how she chose to present it and
the passage that cause the most trouble
was as follows
star wins words I can indeed hardly see
how anyone ought to wish Christianity to
be true for if so the plain language of
the text seems to show that the men who
do not believe and this would include my
father my brother and almost all of my
friends the people who do not believe
will be everlastingly punished and this
is a damnable doctrine and Emma simply
didn't want that to go public so to
remove this was certainly selectively
edited the published book and its sequel
more letters of Charles Darwin and later
Henrietta's account of her mother Emma
Darwin these were the only sources that
were available for many many many
decades that gave anything about the
private man so in truth Francis Darwin's
account was really much more skilled and
usually credited he showed Darwin as a
loving father and a friend the courteous
correspondent socially responsible
intellectually honest and personally
humble many of us who have encountered
Darwin through this life and letters
have come away with the same sense of
Darwin as being a very upright and
engaged an interesting person as Francis
Darwin painted it these fine simple
qualities were crucial factors in
Darwin's intellectual success nowadays
we can understand much of this emphasis
on humility and honesty and the struggle
with ill health that was well documented
as the 19th century equivalents of the
credit building process that Stephen
shaping the sociologist of science talks
about in the 17th century so early
biographers who used Francis Darwin's
book as a source continued that theme
they emphasized the humility and the
honesty and how that made our in a
worthy contributor to science
here is a quotation no words can be
strong enough said the American
biographer George Woodbury to express
the moral beauty of Darwin's character
here's another one he was a marvelously
patient and successful revolutionist of
thought I was George bettany enough of
his character Sean forth and his work to
indicate the tenderness and goodness
said Archibald geeky a life of singular
purity thought Charles Frederick holder
it goes on and on on translucent
truthfulness said Henry Fairfield Osborn
so don't virtuous character is I think
really being put forward here as an
evidence for it's an important ability
it's an important element in his ability
to convince contemporaries of the
validity of his proposals and off his
own authority in in the field really and
most of all Francis Darwin portrayed his
father as a hard worker and to showcase
this mental labor was another important
significant another important
biographical move that took its impetus
from the busy productive self-made man
of the 19th century as described by
Samuel smiles who you see here and the
type of page little fuzzy I'm sorry of
his self-help a book that was immensely
widely distributed in Britain for sure
during the middle years of the 19th
century it was published the same year
as the origin of species so these
notions of industriousness contributed
to new representations of science
emerging at the end of the 19th century
the Christian themes of saintly
dedication and austerity and humility
were transferred to the man of science
great achievers just reflecting back on
our Tuesday discussions great achievers
said smiles were careful economists of
time
and so Darwin was written about as an
industrious man for the industrial age
he was described much as he described
himself as completely dedicated to his
work entirely respectable and
conscientious and this is what Stefan
Collini and Boyd Hilton to Cambridge
England historians call the idea of
character in Victorian thought it's an
idea that enjoy particular prominence in
Britain at the end of the 19th century
that features everything I've been
saying self-restraint perseverance
effort courage in the face of adversity
and a heightened sense of duty we can
see all these qualities in Darwin
contrast this with the motifs embedded
in the lives of let's say Alexander von
Humboldt or John Stuart Mill that were
published at much the same time that
rest far more on self-cultivation and
openness to experience a version of
Romanticism that prioritized the self
hilton makes the point that the british
sense of character which i'm proud to
say recoils from romantic
self-indulgence hilton makes the point
that this reflected the wider cultural
impact of evangelical christianity and a
vision of life as a perpetual struggle
and that's actually how these early
biographies of Darwin present his life
it's a life of struggle it's a life of
that recoiled from romantic
self-indulgence so these I think are
much the same features as the financial
integrity and the moral discipline that
I was speaking about on Tuesday where
work was the chief sphere in which
virtue was developed and displayed
so there's a very different Darwin
emerging in the aftermath of World War
one as you could imagine it was
difficult for authors to continue in
this same mold after the horrors and
deaths experienced on the global scale
of World War one hard work and virtue as
the leading motives gave way to a
personal inner turmoil the 1920s and the
1930s saw those authors who write in
English who wrote in English they turned
towards examining the interior life of
men and women answering the new
psychoanalytic call to acknowledge that
selves the self is a many-sided thing
and a search for greater authenticity in
representing real people there was much
consideration of life writing as a genre
taking its tone of voice from the blooms
preset especially Lytton Strachey leslie
stephen and edmund gosse and that
appears most obviously in britain in the
writings of Virginia Woolf who was a
biographer at times and Harold Nicolson
and in America in the writings of
Gamaliel Bradford who's a very
interesting scholar a Boston literary
critic who advocated a new genre of
Psych ography Bradford wrote an
excellent short biography of Darwin in
1917 and then after the war he expanded
it in 1926 very much almost different
book and he was one of the first to ask
the very modern question what kind of
man was Darwin so devoted to his work
and so secular what kind of man was he
and Brad hood tended to write books in
threes and Darwin was the second volume
of a religious trilogy the first part of
which was a portrait of the American
evangelist Dwight Moody while the
closing
was a study of Christ and he needed
Darwin for the negative side so to speak
for a denial of Christian revelation to
put in the middle of his trio and he
sawed and sawed to find a crucial
central moment in Darwin's life that he
could turn his psychic raphy psyche as
his psychic raphy around and but he
didn't find one there was no moment in
Darwin's life where he turned away from
religion that's an epiphany so Bradford
very profitably began to wonder about
the interaction between illness and
creativity and it is a very interesting
biography I do recommend it the question
of creativity featured as an issue
elsewhere too during the 1920s 30s and
40s here is Nora Bala who was one of
darwin's granddaughters continuing the
family tradition of thinking about the
grandfather and producing edited volumes
about the grandfather but Nora Barlow
was a rather different young woman she
was a scientist researching plant
breeding Mendelian genetics with William
Bateson in Cambridge and in the John in
his horticultural Institute just north
of Cambridge she began in the 1930s to
explore the origins of Darwin's
evolutionary ideas seeking to understand
creativity and motive she didn't write
biography but she was very innovative in
bringing unpublished manuscripts which
were family manuscripts that nobody else
had access to especially manuscripts
from the Beagle voyage and Darwin's full
unedited autobiography to the public so
in this regard Bradford and Barlow
considered Darwin as one of the secular
moderns they publicized his loss of
faith and that fitted very neatly into
what was thought to be the dawn of the
new secular humanist
age it's about this time as well after
the Second World War up until this time
at least the Darwin family themselves
retained possession of all of Darwin's
papers books and our kinds of things
furniture everything it was only in 1942
by an arrangement with the pilgrim trust
a big American charitable foundation
that the archives of the archive was
acquired by Cambridge University Library
in England this archive included some
9,000 letters the portfolio's of notes
Darwin's books the drafts of his books
his library the autobiography which
we've been talking about his notes on
specimens and I'm sorry here at some of
the books here's a wonderful it's
Darwin's copy of Lyle's principles of
geology that he took with him on the
Beagle voyage the collection included
the famous notebooks in which Don made
his first evolutionary speculations you
will all be very familiar with this
image from that be notebook which
predates Darwin's understanding of
natural selection but he was certainly
thinking evolutionary thoughts when he
made this diagram that Darwin archive is
a fabulous collection that was acquired
during the end of the Second World War
and was made available to the public in
university library research public from
1949 and that had a big impact on the
way that Darwin was written about after
that point and the next flurry of
biographies came with the 1959 centenary
of publication of the origin of species
the ground was extremely ready to
promote a different kind of Darwin and
as it turns out this new Darwin was a
very biologic
oh darling then the notes and the papers
and the records that were now available
enabled biologists to make a much more
focused case for Darwin really being
understood as a as a biologist by then
the so-called evolutionary synthesis was
accepted it was worked out in previous
decades during the forties mostly by
Ernst Mayr led yard stebbins George
Gaylord Simpson julian huxley and others
and you can see them here I'll speak to
this in just a moment Betty smoker Vitas
has argued that the Darwins celebratory
year of 1959 was perceived as an
appropriate moment to to affirm
biology's unification under and
evolutionary synthesis and make direct
links back to Darwin as a magisterial
ancestor figure who had put the theory
of evolution by natural selection on the
map and this panel of evolutionary
biologists convened at a meeting in
Chicago to celebrate the centenary of
the origin of species and they are
showing their solidarity for the
evolutionary synthesis by sitting
together so they're not all friends I
have to say and let's see now Ernst Mayr
is actually not he see his fifth on the
left yes he's an snow is here but you
none of us can see the names on the
labels his label is actually here that's
this is the one that says mad but this
is an smell this is julian huxley sis
you're right it's a very distinguished
panel of biologists the biologically
trained authors that I wish to talk
about just for one moment now naturally
saw Darwin through biological eyes and
their interest focused on asserting that
evolutionary theory was true and that
Darwin's ideas even though they were a
hundred years old
had an active place in current fort
ernst mayr who wrote about Darwin's
central position in the grand sweep of
biological history in this book the
growth of biological thought Darwin has
a key place in the middle of the history
which is a giant sweep of biology from
Aristotle in ancient Greece to modern
Harvard and Ernst Mayr Howard Mellish
and Alan Morehead provided accessible
studies of Darwin's observations on the
Beagle voyage and Arthur Keith the
prominent London surgeon and physical
anthropologist wrote a very
well-received study called Darwin
revalued claiming that it wasn't a
biography as such because it was
arranged thematically now keith was a
celebrated scholar of the human fossil
record he lived for many years in a
house next to Darwin's home and here he
is in Darwin's garden some of you will
have come across Darwin's thinking path
the sand walk at the bottle of Darwin's
garden here is Keith on the sand walk
showing his appreciation for Darwin as a
living biological thinker now Keith is
unfortunately better known today for
being deceived by the Piltdown Man hoax
in which the jawbone of an orangutan was
deliberately combined with the cranium
or a fully developed modern human and
called to be in a missing link in
intermediary form between Apes and human
keith was completely hoaxed by this and
here he is in a rather wonderful image
examining the skull with the panel of
people who also endorsed the
authenticity of this fossil and he never
recovered from the embarrassment so with
this freshly biologist Darwin the
Galapagos finches begin to take that
place
if you've read the origin of species
which is not an easy book to tackle the
Galapagos finches aren't in there Darwin
doesn't really talk about them very much
in any of his buyer autobiographical
recollections there really a product of
the 1950s asked part of Darwin's work so
the finches as shown here in John Gold's
beautiful illustrative materials become
part of the Darwin story through David
lacks work David lack described them as
an exemplary case of adaptive radiation
as you can see here the bill perhaps you
can't the bills are all different shapes
in this circle and they radiate out from
a presumed ancestral form here they are
looking at some finches in a box so
lacks book was actually first written in
1947 and then was reissued in 1961 and
these materials asks explored by lack
supported the view that Darwin's theory
was in all essentials based on
Biological observations made in the
Galapagos Islands lacks writings became
the source for a widespread belief that
Darwin had experienced a Eureka moment
in the archipelago and that the
possibility of such a moment fitted very
well with contemporary notions about how
science advanced different now but it
was very powerful in its day and it's
also very likely that the anniversary
period in 1959 was instrumental in
consolidating the notion that scientific
ideas had at last conquered the
religious opposition from the church
Julian croxleys living thoughts of
Darwin promoted Darwin as a rational
scientific figure the Newton of biology
so they're younger Huxley who you can
see here here is the young Julian Huxley
with his grandfather Thomas
henry huxley and here is julian huxley
sir an adult julian huxley adopted his
grandfather's pugnacious style and
defended secularism vigorously through
the 1950s and 60s and as the keynote
speaker at the 1959 Chicago
commemoration that I already showed you
an image from he's here in a pulpit so
to speak provocatively declaring that
religion was merely an adaptation it's a
Darwinian adaptation that humankind's
humankind needs simply to get along with
each other it's very provocative and
indeed Julian Huxley seems to have
become the re manifestation of his
grandfather calling to mind the fights
of the 1860s northern 96 is the 1860s in
which thomas henry huxley jousted with
the Bishop of Oxford Samuel Wilberforce
at the meeting for the british
association for the advancement of
science so the darwin that emerged at
that time in the 1960s was very much a
rational secular biologist who's
insights were very much alive in the
minds of practicing biologists so it's
interesting to note that darwin's
personal integrity was frequently
emphasized by these biologists
biographers writers invariably referred
to the dramatic moment in Darwin's life
when Alfred Russel Wallace wrote him a
letter from the malakas saying that he
had a theory of evolution by natural
selection and would Darwin mind reading
it and sending it on to Charles Lyell
who Wallace didn't know and for
publication an astonishing moment for
Darwin because Wallace's essay seemed to
recapitulate everything that Darwin had
been thinking and writing
for 20 years a huge and terrible shock
for Darwin the point that i'm going to
make here is that the biographers when
they wish to address this moment in
Darwin's life speak very powerfully
about Darwin's honorable behavior in
response to this letter and here I just
want to separate what we think we know
about Darwin and we think we do know
he's honorable and how a biographer can
express what they wish to say about
Darwin the biographers wish to share
Darwin as an honorable figure the letter
from Wallace which has never been found
was the stimulus for the double
announcement of Darwin and Wallace's
theories at the linnean society of
london in july 1858 here is Wallace in
Singapore a couple of years after he had
written to Darwin and here is the joint
more strictly speaking it's a double
paper because they didn't write it
together to double paper read by the
Secretary of the linnean society in July
1858 and neither Wallace nor Darwin were
there for various reasons but it was the
first announcement of the evolution by
natural selection and the process that
had brought the two men together to tad
have this publication red has not very
many records that can make that can
allow us to produce a story that we feel
is probably true there's plenty of room
for this story to be interpreted in many
different ways and the biologists who
are writing about Darwin wished to say
that Darwin behaved very honorably they
show Darwin as a principled figure
committed to maintaining the ethical
standards and responsibilities of
scientific world non-biological writers
didn't have any such vested interests
they took aim the saintly image Gertrude
Himmelfarb dethroned the icon by laying
bare the social determinism in Darwin's
writings and she took a very jaundiced
view of this ambiguous Darwin Wallace
moment Lauren Isley the anthropologist
and philosopher a fascinating humanist
writer who delivered Terry lectures here
in 1966 and he argued that Darwin failed
to take moral responsibility for his
theories the theories that he put
forward and he suggested in a book
called the mysterious mr. X that Darwin
stole the concept of evolution by
natural selection not from Wallace which
he could have done but from Edward
Blythe an early correspondent Wallace
biographers began to take the same line
from the 1960s onwards developing a
richly complex Wallace conspiracy theory
that still has legs today though that
Wallace was undone by Darwin and that
Darwin wasn't honorable that he stole
principle some really quite key concepts
from Wallace's essay that then turn up
in the Origin of Species I think it's
groundless but we all know conspiracy
theories are very attractive and and
there's no evidence to knock that one on
the head so at the same time historians
began to criticize the great man school
of history new standards were being
created by a growing professional body
of historians of science and biography
in general was increasingly regarded by
scholars as an inappropriate form of
inquiry for a scholarly discipline
although great fun to read outside
and I think the big biography by Irving
stone that some of you may know
published in nineteen eighty marks that
transition it is a accurate it's
perceptive it's well paced and yet it's
never ever considered a scholarly
contribution to Darwin studies with some
very notable exceptions it's taken more
than fifty years for the genre to be
reestablished as a suitable vehicle for
wider scholarly interpretations and
today biographers work hard to
reconstruct the world in which Darwin
lived the problems he tried to solve the
resources upon which he drew for answers
and the way that his ideas circulated
and intermeshed with others far beyond
his immediate environment and this has
meant dismantling the imagery of Darwin
as an isolated thinker who independently
revolutionized the Victorian worldview
and above all modern writers are well
aware of the other evolutionary writers
of the period and their conscious of the
problems the problematic nature of
claiming a solely Darwinian revolution
or even cleaning a revolution at all so
to a large extent modern biographers are
dealing less with the science and more
with the cultural features that create a
scientist and the features that allow
his or her views to become accepted
validated so I've tried today in
conclusion to speak about the
hard-working industrious Darwin of the
19th century through to the troubled
evolutionist and secular thinker of the
1930s to the biologists Darwin of the
1950s and 60s and I think it's clear
that the key aspects of Darwin's
character have been regularly re
formulated by biographers and this isn't
really very surprising yet it's
important to acknowledge
the people who wrote about Darwin were
remembering the past partly in order to
think about their present they inhabited
a different memory world from Darwin and
from each other and from us these
stories of a scientific life I think
provide quite a bit of insight into
those different memory worlds in the
words of my colleague at Harvard Stephen
shape n all of us inevitably right about
the past as an expression of present
concerns and many of these concerns I
think had been rooted in issues that
I've discussed today of which the
religious beliefs of Darwin and his
moral attributes were paramount thank
you very much
thank you so much for this very
intriguing lecture I wonder if you can
just elaborate a little more on your
last point and the religious and ethical
concerns but as you say some of that was
edited out but the way he was struggling
with his own religion I'd love to hear a
little bit more from you Darwin himself
struggling about his religion such an
interesting topic thank you so he he he
lived a long time and left a lot of
papers so that one can find almost
anything one wants to find in his papers
and pull it out and say well that's the
real Darwin but actually there's a kind
of spread of views and like well like me
I don't want to assume what you like but
he has different views at different
times in his life different views when
different things happen to him so after
the death of his daughter he was
distraught hated everything religious
but he still was friends with his pastor
in the village and he was friends with
Huxley and other people who were much
more secular so he had different points
of view at different times in his life
he's very clear that he lost all
conventional faith in a gradual movement
he never had a moment of just turning
his back on it and that gradual process
took place on the Beagle voyage he wrote
that he began Beagle voyage with
actually a lot what he what he calls a
laughable belief in the literal truth of
the Bible and that he spent several
years on the Beagle several moments
during a lengthy Beagle voyage wishing
that there was some uncomfortable
evidence that the Testaments were true
so I don't suppose he really wanted to
give it up but he just lost it and at
the same time he lost all sense that his
profession would be that of a clergyman
when he joined the vehicle voyage the
ultimate plan
that he had come back and become a
clergyman and that was gone and his
family and father acknowledged that that
went whilst he was on the ship and they
never seem to have discussed it even he
was going to be a professional gentleman
scientist with a private income
it's much more interesting and it gets
much more engaged and I won't go on too
long about this but through the 1860s
when people were deeply deeply concerned
about the implications of his writings
Darwin did discuss that a great length
with a number of colleagues who he felt
very intimate with he didn't wish to
make these discussions too widely known
about and it's clear that he's puzzled
he doesn't know about free will he
grapples with it and he writes to his
friend Lyle to said I can't imagine that
God requires every single sparrow that
God is looking after every single
sparrow so he has some issues that even
we today can empathize with and they're
expressed in wonderfully simple language
by a very intelligent man that I think
speaks to some of us and so those people
who have read the unexpurgated
autobiography and Darwin's
correspondence on religious matters find
him humane thoughtful anxious I'm
willing to take a position I'm reluctant
to give it all up because who knows and
yet he doesn't go to church he can't
bear that he looks at the word of the
baptismal service he was asked to be a
godfather to some little cousins of his
and he had to write to his cousin to say
I can't do this I'm not going to say
that I think it's it's observed that the
child should be sinful before it's
baptized so there's interesting
interesting things in in the materials
you
I'm interested in the notion of the all
this emphasis upon virtue and hard work
and I'm wondering if that also wasn't a
response to Darwin's law so religious
belief in other words you know following
the Nietzschean and dust at skin notion
that if there's no God everything is
permitted this could be a way also
dealing with the fact that if there is
no God there is an inherent goodness or
morality in man that still is there
could you address that a little that was
such an interesting question thank you
did you all hear that surely when you
lose your faith in order to remain a
decent member of society there have to
be other things that you call them and
Darwin certainly called on that so we
know he wrote gosh it was to his wife he
wrote to say at least I know my duty and
you can see that he's saying I'm not a
bad man because I might have lost some
of this faith I I know what to do I know
what's decent I know what's moral I'm
I'm a virtuous person so yes I think
it's a real moment in religious history
where the kind of key concepts of Iran
evangelicalism are lifted and put into a
secular environment which the gentle and
I spoke that void Hilton I mentioned his
name wrote a wonderful book called the
age of atonement in which that thesis is
presented so that everyone's being very
moral but it's not necessarily with
religious motivation behind her thank
you
I'm in crossville in the role of thomas
henry huxley and his promotion of
Darwin's ideas and its debating of
thousands ideas to what extent was
Huxley's work in in educating people
about that as idea isn't the both of
them independent them to what extent was
at the collaboration how much did
darling booklet Huxley on this thank you
so some of you will note Huxley was a
sometimes ambivalent about Darwin's
ideas there was a particular issue in
Darwinism as Darwin presented it the
Tuck serially could not adopt which was
what Huxley calls the species barrier
that asks at well adapted organisms
become more and more differentiated
through preserving adaptations at some
point they have to stop into breeding
with each other if they're going to turn
into new species and it's that moment
that Huxley couldn't have them he
couldn't see how Darwin wanted to do
that so Huxley insisted there had to be
some thing that pushed the species away
at that last moment which Darwin didn't
approval so they talked great deal to
each other about this and other things
the Huxley took donors and as a banner
for freedom of thought for rationality
for progress it was the best idea he
thought had come up in that in in that
period it was the best theory possible
for uniting all the biological facts
together so he was deeply committed to
Darwinism with some tweaks that he
thought could could be made that weren't
being made and he amongst others was
very active in showing how this isn't
just a theory
species origination this is a whole new
restructuring of biology about the way
humans think about themselves and their
our place in the world and about the
relationship of science to the church to
the other institutions of the age so
Huxley's a big part of that Darwinian
revolution if we're going to call it a
revolution we should call it the Huxley
and revolution because it's Huxley who
doesn't Darwin sitting at home writing
letters but there's a lot of interaction
between them but they don't cook up a
program of political propagandizing
together but Darwin's really glad that
Huxley would do that but though it's not
going to do it
I was wondering if you see some
psychological tension having produced
the theory of evolution and then needing
to well that's that's enough I don't
want to rock the boat that much I need
to have this moral uprightness and
though he did not want to further
radicalize his life shall we say does it
does it seem as though there's that bit
of tension in his need to be a moral
person and so forth thank you that's a
very interesting question I've never
thought of it in quite the way that
you're formulating it I think he was
such a man beforehand so that it's not
an he doesn't have to adapt adopt a way
of being a good person after the Origin
of Species he was that person already
but the book him the book itself the
origin of species when it was published
transformed his life so that not only
was there masses and masses of
Correspondence to deal with people came
to visit people wish to know all kinds
of intimate things about him
particularly his religious views and his
friends would be writing to say well i
was at such-and-such a meeting and x
kind of shot you down why had something
to say about it so there's a lot going
on in his life relating to the book that
is transformative but i don't believe
that he becomes more obviously moral or
decent or upright any more than he would
have been if he hadn't written it i
think thank you
you mentioned how the the themes in the
history of ography of Darwin often
reflect the uses of Darwin and I
remember there's a recent work on the
the growth of an atheism in your in
France in particular that becomes non
humanist between the wars and I'm
wondering if you see in biography or
elsewhere this sort of wave how this may
change the the uses of Darwin away from
Darwin is this sort of you know
regretful you know person towards people
like the new atheists to the earth today
and that sort of thing there are
certainly books about Darwin thank you
where Darwin's pictured as reveling in
being secular but they're rather unusual
books mostly the books that I've come
across in the last fifty years when I've
been reading them all is Darwin as a
tentative thinker which I find strange
because he's absolutely incisive when
he's thinking about biological issues
but for some of the other things that
involve social questions and questions
of culture and humanity and human
progress he's much more tentative and
much more confused which is why perhaps
people don't always feel quite so happy
about reading The Descent of Man the
last book of Darwin's because it's not
the Darwin that they're gay that they
think they're going to get so he does he
he he thinks deeply about things and
then he finds actually he's not able to
answer quite a few of the questions he's
asking himself thank you
over there
you